I want to play a game with you called
keeping it real with Ayesha perfect it's
I know that your life is crazy and super
busy but we want to know the things that
you do to kind of maintain your sanity
do it okay go-to karaoke song Oh
Bohemian Rhapsody I do mean Bohemian you
have the floor i see a little silhouetto
of a man scaramouche scaramouche can we
do the fandango thunderbolt and
lightning very very frightening so good
famous pal that you like to keep it real
with Tamera Mowry yes why she's just
awesome and we have the same values and
morals and outlook on life celebrity
Instagram you're addicted to following
Missa Teigen you just love her yeah
Blaire you guys need to do a cooking
collab reality TV competition show that
you would kick butt on wipeout oh yes
but other constraints coming in Christ
yes
TV obsession you cannot miss an episode
this is us you cry i watch it very
freaking time
just leave it I'm not leaving it Jack
you're acting like a crazy person do you
watch it with Steph no that is my show
that I watched when he's on his road
trips and I call him every single time
like he's like are you okay I'm like no
I'm perfectly fine I just watched
suppose you think oh my gosh I knew that
you would get like this about it last
one your ideal date night with Steph
being at home like enjoying we spend so
much time away from it now it's like
being able to enjoy our room and like
lighting the fire and just being in the
comfort of our own home with the kids
asleep the beach adult time
[Music]